digamos que estamos en 1950 y hay un
terreno que pertenece a la ciudad y la
ciudad dice bueno yo creo que como
necesitamos algo de efectivo hoy les
vendamos ese terreno a alguien que quizá
quiera construir una casa así que
tenemos a la ciudad que es el dueño
original del terreno y le transfieren el
título o la escritura de ese terreno a
un desarrollador que se volverá el
primer dueño así que le transfieren la
escritura de ese terreno a este
desarrollador en cuanto le transfieren
el título de propiedad lo registran
archivando una escritura en el condado
algunas veces es en la ciudad otras
veces es en el condado y en este caso va
a ser en las oficinas del condado así
que se archiva esta escritura en el
condado bueno imaginemos que este
desarrollador vive en la casa que
construyó durante un tiempo no sé a unos
20 años y tanto él como su esposa
fallecen por lo que en 1970 ellos
fallecen y ninguno de ellos hizo
testamento así que esta propiedad se
transfiere a su pariente más cercano
qué es el cuñado del desarrollador que
es el pariente más cercano así que la
propiedad se le transfiere a esta
persona así que ahora este cuñado del
desarrollador es quien tiene el título
de la casa el cual se va a reflejar con
una escritura que va a ser archivada en
el condado esta es la segunda escritura
la escritura anterior fue la primera y
ahora avancemos hasta el año 2000 el
cuñado y su familia ha vivido en esta
casa durante todo este tiempo y después
de 30 años están buscando vender esta
casa y existe un comprador que está
interesado en ella y lo vamos a llamar
el dueño número 3 pero antes de que esta
persona compre la casa con toda
prudencia quiere asegurarse que el
título de propiedad esté limpio que esté
cuñado en realidad si sea el dueño legal
de esta propiedad es decir que realmente
sea el dueño y no sólo tenga la posesión
de la casa que de verdad sea el dueño de
ella también quiere revisar que no haya
ningún gravamen con respecto a la casa
impuestos no pagados o deudas por ahí
algún arreglo que no se pagó cualquier
otra cosa que pueda estar pendiente en
esta casa por lo que este el dueño 3 va
a contratar una compañía de
investigación para que investigue esto
las personas de esta compañía van a ir
al registro público de la propiedad de
este condado y van a ver toda la
historia de las escrituras que ha tenido
esta casa ven que al principio el
terreno era de la ciudad luego se les
fue vendido a un desarrollador que
construyó la casa en 1950 después el
desarrollador y su familia fallecieron
en 1970 por lo que fue transferida
legalmente al cuñado y encuentran que la
propiedad está limpia y le dicen al
dueño 3 que puede comprar esta casa por
lo que decide cerrar el trato compra la
casa paga el precio de venta de la casa
cualquiera que éste sea y el título se
transfiere a esta persona y por supuesto
la evidencia de esta transferencia del
título de propiedad se archiva como una
escritura en el condado tenemos la
escritura número 3
ustedes me pueden decir bueno eso está
perfecto parece algo que es muy
razonable de hacer y que este dueño
número 3 realmente no tiene nada por qué
preocuparse pero qué tal si justo
después de que el dueño número 3 hizo el
pago de la compra de la casa recibió su
escritura y todo digamos que en el año
2001 aparece alguien que dice sabes que
yo soy el hijo perdido del desarrollador
por lo que yo tengo el derecho de esta
propiedad no el cuñado que lo recibió
así que yo reclamo esta casa digo que
debí ser yo quien la debía heredar así
que aquí alguien dice debió ser para mí
esta casa por lo que ellos afirman que
esta no fue una transacción válida y por
lo tanto esta otra transacción tampoco
es válida y podrían llevar esto a la
corte lo cual no sería nada agradable
para el dueño número 3 así que
seguramente ustedes están preguntando
cómo es que el dueño número 3 puede
protegerse a sí mismo de que pase una
cosa extraña como esta especialmente
debido a que la compra de una casa
normalmente es una de las transacciones
más importantes en la vida de una
persona si esto ocurriera y si tuviera
una demanda por la casa se volvería una
pesadilla para el dueño y es por eso que
existe algo llamado seguro de escritura
seguro de escritura el propósito de este
seguro de escritura es que bueno si en
efecto tiene que hacerse una
investigación de los títulos y de las
escrituras de la propiedad que me
interesa comprar para asegurarnos que
esta propiedad está limpia que el título
está limpio que no hay ningún gravamen o
reclamaciones de ningún tipo sobre ella
y así también podemos darnos cuenta si
es que aquí hubo algo extraño si no se
archivaron adecuadamente las escrituras
de esta propiedad en algún momento pero
aún cuando se hace toda esta
investigación y todo aparentemente sale
bien no se puede estar un 100% seguros
de que no va a suceder algo como el
ejemplo que les estoy mostrando aquí o
que quizá algo se obvió en el momento de
hacer la investigación de títulos así
que para protegerse como dueño se va a
comprar un seguro de escritura la
mayoría de las personas que les prestan
dinero ya que la mayoría de las veces
cuando se compra una casa los
prestamistas son los que dan la mayor
parte del dinero y los prestatarios pues
una parte más pequeña por lo
y los prestamistas son los que dicen que
se tenga un seguro de escritura para que
ellos puedan protegerse de este tipo de
escenarios imaginen que el dueño número
3 saco una hipoteca y de pronto toda
esta locura sucede y quizás lo más fácil
para este dueño 3 sea alejarse de esto
deshacer la transacción y dejará al
banco con el problema así que el banco
tiene un gran incentivo para tener un
seguro de escritura el objetivo de este
seguro es proteger a este dueño o la
persona que se vuelve el dueño de la
propiedad de cualquiera de estas
situaciones extrañas que puedan suceder
así que seguramente si un banco les está
dando el dinero para comprar la casa
insista en que ustedes obtengan un
seguro de escritura lo cual es una muy
buena idea incluso cuando ustedes estén
comprando una casa y no estén pidiendo
un préstamo para pagarla simplemente
para asegurarse de que ustedes estén
protegidos contra cualquier reclamación
extraña que pueda llegar después de que
ustedes se volvieron dueños de la
propiedad
también para aclararlo no es algo que
sea muy costoso de este seguro de
escritura ya que estas cosas no ocurren
muy seguido son muy poco frecuentes pero
aún así ustedes deben protegerse contra
ellos